welcome to Paranormal Activity three the
movie where you are literally watching
paint dry
oh it's Katie again if I see that
dickhead mika live on pre-recorded
footage I'm gonna add 50 cents to this
bitch automatically just FYI I mean just
because I had to say his name I'm adding
us into this movie
hashtag Mika is a douche Sookie brought
over looks like that's missing who's
even watching these what is the intended
audience the tape thief and if it is the
thief who is it
is it the viewer is it the dead grandma
is it the ghost did the ghost get a VHS
player the fuck 1988 so this is before
were the other two films Jesus
leapfrogging Christ also that's 18 years
prior to any of these films plots yet
the VHS tape containing it hasn't worn
out or warped or generally gone - that's
VHS tapes are known to do this is
extremely amateurish editing even for
home movies
the problem with found footage films is
that a lot of found footage is
boring-ass fillable my grandma's
obviously evil wait is this all
flashback of the chick from the first
movies childhood why wasn't this but it
found and included in the first movie
then the second this guys fox mulder
garage my assistant Randy having an
assistant named Randy also this hoarders
garage having asshole having an
assistant so of course Katy and Kristi's
new dad was a video enthusiast because
how else were they going to shoot all
the paranormal activity 3 this is pretty
fancy house for 1988
what does Julie do exactly other than
raise too expensive children Oh Ruby
gives zero explanation as to why this
asshole might be filming this right now
but whatever you're about to become
scared what you love so you care Jesus
why didn't the Paranormal Activity ever
affect people who live in apartments or
trailers and why only the wealthy no one
answered my call so let's continue
filming the creepy rich house in total
silence because that's what the
screenwriter told us to do Teddy Ruxpin
is well-known to be one of the most
terrifying children's toys of all time
this is already a clue that terrible
things will happen demon that leaves
absolutely no trace of itself anywhere
stuck his claws in lambs blood before
going a haunt in one night but only left
his markings on this door one time and
nowhere else that camera absolutely has
a light attachment please turn it on
whoa jump-scare daughter who be rips off
the parents casually smoke popping from
the original poltergeist
this is why there's so many quick edits
to which should be straight villain home
movies there's probably an extra hour of
this somewhere she was more concerned
about smoking pot on camera then having
sex on camera isn't he supposed to be a
professional videographer this lighting
is atrocious regardless of any ghosts or
demons those two sisters had their mom's
quasi sex tape on hand for a while and
that's fucked up the only way you could
be this awkward filming a sex tape with
your own wife would be if you've never
had sex before conveniently this movie's
poltergeist demon waits until just
before the nudity to show up for
haunting activity also and totally
coincidentally this movie's poltergeist
demon hates my penis so did the demon
caused an earthquake thereby
demonstrating in the third movie of a
series way more power than previously
demonstrated in the earlier films or is
the earthquake some kind of coincidence
timed exactly what the appearance of
this family's poltergeist because damn
either way sinister dust settles on a
ghostly figure and he just sits there
but the ghost leader complains about
having a hand put on it either your
corporeal or not dude also the because
this asshole just sitting here in the
bedroom watching this porno being shot
anyway also thankfully for this movie's
many videotaped endeavors discount Mika
is the video Wiz with a garage full of
all the equipment you see that in the
corner yeah you totally can't see the
dust settling midair I guess every one
of these movies needs the person who
doesn't believe in anything to
manufacture artificial Pynchon character
in their toast haha but the famous
virgin mary toast happened back in 1994
six years after the events of this movie
Julie
unlike previous films in the franchise
this movie doesn't even lift a finger to
try and explain why this guy is
constantly recording everything in his
life including spousal disputes sure new
boyfriend install a camera in my young
daughter's room the ghost is the least
of these kids problems based on mom's
decision-making there is no way this
asshole is changing tapes every six
hours to capture all the things he needs
to capture these titles edit it in after
the fact and so by who
and if not can we admit that this is a
quirk of filmmaking and the VHS
point-of-view that we're watching is not
in fact all this movie is also you're
telling you this family somehow captured
HD video with night vision in multiple
rooms in 1988 without selling their
souls to the devil tell me why is the
demon real but its voice isn't now you
might say that only Kristi can hear it
because of some sort of children power
but why can't the video tape pick it up
does the video tape have to believe
before it records it perfect decor for
every 80's child a blurry poster ooh Jem
you haven't been around kids for that
long they do weird things wife and
mother dismisses her child talking to an
off-camera ghost as a weird thing or did
not play her the video but still somehow
try and explain what happened movie
glosses over the obvious answer for the
families haunting within the first 30
minutes should be called back to the
present lean conversation about Back to
the Future three years after the first
one came out and a year before the
sequels release in case you forgot it
was the 80s paranormal activity 3 even
more nighttime surveillance footage of
nothingness that's right a light
terrifyingly turns itself on and off
again again maybe it's supposed to have
springsteen those tweets a minimum of
seven days to truly start transitioning
from mild hijinks to full haunting as
per the poltergeist Accord of 1985 in
every previous scene of this bedroom the
red light of the recording camera has
been visible in the closet door mirror
but tonight there is no red light which
means we are watching video from a
camera that is not recording anything
it's just the demons whining dude I mean
at any point during filming did anyone
research the home video recording
capabilities of 1988 because it seems
pretty obvious they did not Julianne
Dennis hopefully leave their door cracks
so we can see part of something
happening every once in a while hmm is
that a real daughter or a ghost girl who
the fuck am I kidding I don't give up
there was a little girl there but now
she's not spooky you told me to get the
books I got you the books the library is
it's for borrowing that first off it
takes like five minutes to get a library
card second off library has all the
answers to your ghost problems cliche
with dads obviously NASA expensive 1080p
video camera duh hey that's the same day
Greg Louganis hit his head on the diving
board coincidence I think not though the
light is brighter now demon Hwang
officially busting up once again demonic
poltergeist Aswang was more concerned
with college prank degree than actual
scares or murders here's the riveting
Toby Locke's older sister in the closet
sink intended to make the viewer feel
impatience at the lack of actual scary
going on in this film you see I'm a
demon
better close the store not all the way
though the babysitter's dressed like a
skipper doll
[Music]
hello Dennis you found the girls
hello Dennis you found the ghosts this
babysitter is a jump-scare dick who no
she's in a third-rate horror film also
she's clearly banging discount Myka also
that's Jenny matrix from video game high
school now I know for sure this isn't
real found footage wait I mean I knew
all along yeah that's better I'll fix it
in post movie finally pays off this pan
in camera bull with something cool do
bad it's after a dozen instances of it
revealing nothing cool and I've stopped
care I thought the little girl said the
ghost was big it's clearly a child-size
ghost this guy damn babysitters takes so
long to walk up the freaking stairs I'm
inclined to think the concept of this
film was threadbare and the screenwriter
was forced to really stretch some why is
she still curious about the closet door
isn't it just a normal closet door can
she hear the demon Wow
selfish child guardian abandons children
at first sign of supernatural trouble
what the director surely thought would
be a suspense building positive use of
repetition turns out to merely be
repetition for the sake of repetition
and it makes me rage you know what
sudden little girl I don't give it are
you one of the daughters are you ghost I
don't care if you're talking stock of
broccoli you can put the hell right off
after the last hour I just sat through
what do you think of that routine Bob
well I mean she didn't fall but to be
honest I think I've seen more creative
choreography from pretty much every
other balance beam competitor here
tonight sure that's a big fall there but
there's really no danger I guess this is
supposed to be scary because the demon
loves playing with children this might
be the most frustrating haunting since
that blow job goes from Ghostbusters
came to my window and told me she was
all out of blow jobs and that's probably
the spooky highlight of the night but
did you see Christie jumping off a
nonchalant roof stairway down in the
delivery room that's at least a tie
Julie not showing the mother of the
haunted children pretty good evidence of
their being haunted is a dum-dum call
you know I've watched an hour of this
movie and I honestly don't know which of
these two young girls is Katie from the
first movie that speaks to either the
filmmakers lack of detail and
differentiation or my lack of focus
given it would be creepy to see this
little girl standing in one place for a
long time via sped up footage if I
hadn't seen the same in the first movie
no matter how unexpected they are crayon
scribbles are just not very menacing i
Dennis not my idea at all babysitter
thinks this apology will excuse him
doing whatever a small child commands
camera indicator light is a deep
metaphor for a working camera
symbolizing a camera working demon
redecorating instead of showing my wife
the crazy-ass video footage I've
assembled let's talk about witches and
with no proper context also these 1930s
witches stole the sons of brainwashed
why exactly to what end for what actual
purpose if only I had proof that it
wasn't but where will I find it the
night his wife feels no more cameras
unrepentant and deaf husband records
their slumber there may be witches and
ghosts harming children in the house but
a man still gonna work also husband's
work appears too involved editing crowd
footage for girls gone wild videos also
even though he has video proof of weird
going on in the house he still puts on
sound-canceling headphones to edit his
work videos late at night in the haunted
house sobs these parents set up this
house so their daughters could be
screaming bloody murder without the
parents having to be bothered by hearing
it if this demon wants Katie all of a
sudden why is it letting her go back to
the beds these parents are some heavy
fucking sleepers demons plan entirely
centers on a girl's power to convince
her parents to move in with evil grandma
[Music]
mom whose kids are pleading with her to
realize no sir in the house me only
thinks the door knock with no actual
visitor is weird
also if the grandma and the demon are
working in concert why did he interrupt
the phone call to play more goddamn
pranks in fact why not do all dit in the
first place also notice how conveniently
the cordless phone she left on the
counter didn't show back up during this
demon avalanche you mean it's still
September long after his wife declared
the taping would end he's still taping
and taping his wife to boot also good
for Dennis making sure this film had a
proper establishing shot so this is
supposedly the moment where Christy
became betrothed to the demon and her
firstborn son is actually his so that
takes us to a very important question
when Christy and her husband reversed
the curse in the last movie why did that
even work but the goal was to clone his
son why was he even bothering with Katie
in the first movie so then left their
home and went to Grandma's house and
she's still letting him set up cameras
to shoot everything
um maybe she's retired and on a fixed
income and can't afford a double or
queen bed ass ever think of that
also these assholes are going to bed at
9:30 1 p.m. look does that there's
virtually no reason I'm standing here
except for the audience scare quotient
ok new house more go wife missing better
grab my camera and record this the ghost
that no one could see earlier now cast
the shadow sometimes 30 full goddamn
seconds of walking across the sidewalk
also here is what the closed captioning
actually says right now
this guy finds several strangers in his
garage who chase him back into the main
house and his first move is to call for
his wife and run upstairs silently as
opposed to immediately calling 9-1-1 and
Julia's dead because why exactly because
she said she didn't want a son
you mean they can brainwash people into
forgetting all this but they can't
brainwash a married couple into having
unprotected sex this dickhead somehow
decides after his possessed wife
dive-bombed him on the stairs then he
needs to pick up the camera before
collecting his daughter this is why
people hate found-footage movies FYI now
he knows how to operate the camera light
when they're trying to hide from a ghost
feels like the demon possessed the wrong
kid it was focused on the younger
daughter throughout the entire movie but
now he's taking up residence in this one
sure well this scene made me lose my
boner that's for sure also evil grandma
just pulled a cruciate ass curse on him
after doing basically nothing other than
looking creepy the whole movie also is
this woman all we've been hearing about
all this movies King Toby now this is
this supposed to count as a surprise
okay so is like the gremlin charger Toby
its Toby the demon who was impregnating
the girls to have their ghost babies
that they then had no memory of is it a
family ghost that went from generation
to generation
why was the mother skipped so many
questions but mostly
you
[Music]
we're Kissin why do you look like
Wow okay let's do it
Candyman Candyman Candyman
[Music]
I